[Music]
how is parenthood this must Patrick must
have changed your life your Parenthood
if very young child it yeah it it's
pretty awesome she just turned three
yeah and it is it is as great if people
tell you than it is thank you um but
that was very hesitant pledge like this
guys we're talking about suicide and
responsible for a job yeah
she made it to three
well what we're doing this we're potty
training her now and there's that thing
where you're so you go this you're so
sensitive am I gonna say one wrong thing
that will then burn itself into their
brain out of context and then ruin their
life so we're using this method now that
we read about called the treat box where
you have a box that they can't get where
they can see it full of like cool toys
and games and books and they go I want
certain you go well you got to go you
got to go use the potty and then you get
to pick something out of the box and I
heard myself the other night I actually
used the phrase if you want something
out of the treat box you got to go
peepee and now that's very benign but I
I'm just so terrified that that thought
will be going through her head later
when she's working at a strip club I'm
gonna get something out of the treat box
so you know I got it's not yeah and by
the way I was telling that to my mom she
goes that's really nice you know when we
when you were little and we were potty
training you every time you use the
potty we would give you an M&M we gave
you a piece of candy every time you use
a potty so it's like women mom every
time I went to the bathroom I got candy
because I go if that's true
that explains almost everything I can
fire my therapist now and it's all makes
sense every time I went I went boo Oh mm
I'm gonna become a comedian
yeah